E aí
oi lá Boa tarde
ou se pode falar inglês aqui
hoje
eu não tive tempo para traduzir as
minhas músicas
Ok obrigado pelo convite ao prazer estar
aqui com todos vocês e é isso eu vou
trocar vou cantar umas palavras e Espero
que encontre lugar em vossa vídeos nos
vossos corações também ok
o
[Música]
Windows 14
dever de castanho do que é conhecido
castanho dos bantos e de Bananal saiu o
a sorte o seu capô e
amarra de Monforte um destino ainda
[Música]
existir só para ver lei além dos hoje
posso ver nada não tem
provocações
quis dizer
só porque
eu sou
o ter ser
[Música]
Louis
acutilante esta
tá ligado no desamparo de
São Paulo não dá sossego não tem
não se demora mas me repassar e assim
não
só para
além do que hoje eu posso ver Não
tempere desprezo corações quis desafiar
Perez geral portões
só
assim eu sou eu
[Música]
o
jogo
tudo
isso aí
e Em Plena Lua Cheia escuridão não tem
lugar mas a
ideia quis falar
jogos
parecer eu sou só para poder crescer
na abundância tempere
divulgações
sabe ar mulheres Elsa
só pra poder ser eu sou pula só pa
e AM
[Música]
e
tu é
[Música]
E aí
bom obrigado
e
essa música eu saquei a do meu ep tirei
um F1 é que chama amanhã que eu fiz a
título pessoal a esta música basicamente
fala daquilo que muitas vezes é
necessário fazer quando vamos atravessar
uma transformação muito profunda Nós
temos que nos conhecer ou reconhecer as
vezes no caso segundos e entrar um Essa
música fala exatamente sobre isso sobre
a dificuldade que por vezes em enfrentar
os próprios medos
Essa é a dificuldade que é
enfrentar por vezes
paradigmas que nós próprios construímos
enorme a e esse chama-se revelar a
música que eu cantei
agora vou cantar outra que se chama
confia que é uma canção que eu escrevi
que eu acho que eu tinha 21 anos não
estou ele
[Música]
ataque a tristeza Elsa e
chora quando tiver ser a
sorrir para quem amas falsa
[Música]
tranquilo
coisas que não dá para perceber não
[Música]
basta apenas confiar
confiar que amanhã os Dora
[Música]
e o Finn aqui um dia tudo irá mudar
confia
em
mim vale a pena
confiar mano Vamos confiar o o
[Música]
vir alegria e inspira a tristeza sobre
pode e pode ter certeza que eu são brisa
para quem confia em mim
a
[Música]
outra vez isso vai fazer
e tira alegria inspira a tristeza sobre
o dia e pode ter certeza que só brilha
para quem confia que
te digo amanhã cidade
agora
e 51
[Música]
a Sofia que um dia tudo muda
confia
[Música]
acho que
vale a pena
mas
já está
[Música]
tudo
fui aqui abaixo
acho que
vale a pena
confiar vamos
oi oi oi oi oi oi oi oi oi
[Música]
oi oi oi oi oi oi oi
E aí
é obrigado a
eu acho que é ser um pouco mais alto
explicativa
há muito para dizer além do que eu
cantei ok
Olá
[Música]
eu sou também Lead Singer numa banda que
são os HMB já uns tempos tiveram um
sucesso uma música chama amor é assim
que eu não vou contar
mas nós tivemos assim uns bons uns
quatro anos tá certo
04 anos em que tivemos a fazer bastante
conserto depois eu faltava dizer o resto
né porque é que eu tenho que dizer sim
ou não
ai e num dos quartos de hotéis dos
muitos em que eu fiquei saiu uma canção
eu vou cantar para você que se chama
saudade que acaba por ser também uma
maneira de olhar para trás sem ficar
ladra
Oi Hoje é seu anão bola e
Esse
[Música]
é o que eu penso em
e não vai
[Música]
e por mais que eu vá aí
E aí
e quando vai é para
ficar
[Música]
ao vez mais que me sentimento
as Tábuas do
nada
[Música]
mas na
Madrugada
Voltar acreditar
bom então bom
lugar o
[Música]
de
Deus
faz
marcas e
E aí
Oi e eu tão pouco eu
quero
porque
esta terra é
[Música]
um
lugar
[Música]
saudade
de
[Música]
você
viu o
[Música]
oi oi
E aí
[Música]
e
quem teu direito
de fazer
marcas
são os
E aí
é
obrigado a
e é isso saudade Pelos vistos este para
mim
e vou ficar uma última música acho eu
até agora não tinha decidido qual seria
eu gostaria de deixar as coisas assim
meio aberto às vezes é um espetáculo e
outras vezes pronto não é tão
espetacular mas mal não é
quem
Então
[Música]
essa é uma pessoa que acredita no
infinito e eu
acredito mas nós estamos separados do
infinito
pela nossa ignorância e pelo amor
por outras palavras a tua dizer que eu
acredito em Deus
[Música]
e
esta música é
basicamente eu fui afirmar isso
mas de uma maneira cu
E aí
é
só sabe teus
quais seriam nossos planos
talvez até de para cima Ana luz
mas tu não quiseste ficar porque
só sabe que
os quais seriam fantasia
outros realidade um dia
não existe ficar
e agora só
[Música]
agora se
Deus
o quê e o mistério
[Música]
pode Lembrando que
tudo
[Música]
e agora só
agora
eu
[Música]
sei que é uma se vocês quiserem podem
bater palmas
que é aquela parte dos Artistas às vezes
ficam sem letra eu tenho por um sol a
[Música]
Oi
bom dia
[Música]
E aí
bom então
aí jovem
[Música]
sob o que perdi
que eu não sai do mais de ti
o que
mais
tio
agora só sabe
você sabe
Deus agora
[Música]
agora só só
de proteção
[Música]
E aí
e é isso
obrigado Espero que tenham gostado e não
eu era suposto ter falado mais um bocado
mas com hora dores aqui na sala não me
atrevo atrevo não é o meu dom eu aprendi
que de outra maneira de Espero que tenha
passado a mensagem que eu queria ter
passado para vocês todos esses bless you
E aí